[Music]
Saturday of course was st. Patrick's Day
with Saginaw or as it's cold in Los
Angeles Cinco de Mayo for white people
really white that's a crazy thing out
here in LA Saturday here in LA Saturday
was st. Patrick's Day and Sunday was the
LA Marathon yeah in other words no Irish
people ran the LA Marathon we roll along
the sidelines vomiting right you
shouldn't just put a number on it
he oughta run big news from the
campaign trail you probably heard about
this this is a big story Rick Santorum
has now said that if elected president
he would ban hardcore pornography yeah
which is why Mitt Romney just changed
his slogan to Mitt Romney because
Santorum would ban hardcore
do I know my crowd or what he would ban
hardcore people right no that's what I
saw it's obvious Cinemax has gotten to
him yeah it's ridiculous if I said he
had banned to all food and nutrition you
would not have reacted that angry
water will be outlawed well we can do
without water pornography
speaking of Rick Santorum a new racy
photo of a shirtless Rick Santorum
lounging in a pool is circulating on the
internet right now yeah ironically the
photo has proven to be a very effective
form of birth control Santorum has mixed
feelings about that that's what I do and
I think it's not quite good enough
that's my poker chow
I'm trying to give it a little extra
lift over the weekend a group of Occupy
Wall Street protesters tried to reoccupy
New York's Zuccotti Park yeah and you
can tell the movements been hurting for
funds because this time they call
themselves Occupy Wall Street
brought to you by Sony Pictures 21 Jump
Street on the side a new study shows
that I couldn't believe this a new study
shows that 30 million Chinese citizens
live in caves it's true that's true
live in caves yeah a spokesperson for
these citizens said hey it beats making
iPads
[Applause]
over the weekend the creator of Red Bull
died at the age of 89 as per his wishes
his funeral will be an all-nighter
followed by a hellacious midterm
HBO age people had to cancel its horse
racing series luck after the death of
three of the horses yeah however HBO
executives are eagerly promoting their
next big series glue
[Applause]
next age we're sitting I don't know is
that over the line I don't know I'm
probably gonna laugh I never thought
yeah hello crazy story in the news a new
report says that not long before Osama
bin Laden died he really wanted to
change
al-qaeda's name to help its image he
wanted to change the name al-qaeda to
help their image yeah unfortunately a
Pinkberry was taken he will destroy you
I think berry berry death to infidels
yeah
how mad with the people at Pinkberry be
another threat from Pinkberry now